also Herr paranovic hat heute einen eine
Idee mitgebracht ich bin mal gespannt
was sie gleich vorstellen die vielleicht
ihrer Meinung nach wahrscheinlich allen
Partei gut tun würde
sie meinen die Verkehrswende ja
genau also ich möchte mal wieder über
mein herzensthema sprechen die
fahrradgerechte Stadt die Verkehrswende
und sie sehen sich habe ganz aktuelle
Bilder aus Utrecht mitgebracht ich war
letzte Woche dort und habe mich mal
angeschaut wie wird eigentlich verkehrt
dort organisiert und was ich dort
gesehen habe ja ich war tatsächlich
sprachlos muss ich ehrlich sagen weil in
Utrecht haben sie es geschafft dass sie
die Alternativen zum Auto der hat gut
ausgebaut haben das wirklich ein
Großteil der Menschen dort mit dem
Fahrrad in die Stadt fährt mit dem
Fahrrad zur Arbeit fährt das Fahrrad ist
das wichtigste Transportmittel in
Utrecht und ja das ist einfach ein
tolles Gefühl man fühlt man fühlt sich
wie als ob man in Deutschland bei einer
Rat Demo wäre also man ist die ganze
Zeit umgeben von anderen Fahrradfahrern
nur dass keiner schreit und brüllt alle
fahren ganz Lächeln fahren lächelnd und
entspannt
dahin also das ist wirklich eine ganz
ganz tolle Erfahrung ich kann jedem
raten mal dorthin zu gehen sich das
anzugucken dann kann ich zurück nach
Deutschland und das erste was ich hier
lesen muss ist dass die FDP tatsächlich
eine Brötchen tastet und längeres parken
im Halteverbot um die Innenstädte Zitat
attraktiver zu machen dann dachte ich
sind wir hier wirklich im letzten
Jahrtausend gefangen das sind Debatten
die haben wir mal in den 70ern geführt
und das ist hier eine Regierungspartei
wohlgemerkt gibt die immer noch glaubt
dass wir damit die Städte attraktiver
machen dass ja das hat mir wirklich die
äh ja das finde ich wirklich schwer zu
fassen und ich bin ja sogenannter
radaktivist ne ich möchte vor allem zwei
Dinge ich möchte dass wir endlich in den
Städten dass der Staat dafür sorgt dass
wir sichere Radwege haben in Berlin
stirbt jeden Monat ein Radfahrer wird
von einem Autofahrer getötet das ist
diesen Monat geschehen dass passiert
nächsten Monat und das wird die nächsten
Jahre immer so weitergehen weil der
Startzeit Jahrzehnten einfach nicht den
Schutz dieser Menschen garantieren kann
und vielleicht ich eine Sache noch und
dann wünsche ich mir noch dass wir mal
endlich eine konstruktive Debatte über
die Verkehrswende führen die
Nachbarländer sie zeigen alle wie das
geht Paris London Amsterdam Barcelona
sie zeigen die Abkehr der autogerechten
zeitungsmöglichkeit steckt enormes
Potenzial in unseren Städten wenn wir
uns nur trauen anders konkret
dementsprechend Frage fahren Sie selbst
Auto oder Taxi Taxi nee das das leiste
ich mir nicht ich habe selber kein Auto
gestern habe ich ein Möbelstück eine
vorgestern im Möbelstück abgeholt habe
ich mein Auto geliehen von einem Freund
anders ging das nicht so konnte man das
nicht transportieren also ich fahre Auto
ich fahre auch manchmal auf dem Land
Auto ich habe selber keins ich nutze
dann wenn ich eins brauche und lass es
nicht 23 Stunden am Tag stehen das heißt
auf dem Land fahren Sie Auto weil sie da
vermutlich auch merken ist etwas
schwierig aber was ist denn wenn zum
Beispiel eine ältere Dame auch wirklich
ja sie will nicht statt dem Auto und sie
will auch genau da parken weil sie
schwer zu Fuß sie möchte nicht mit dem
Fahrer das kann sie auch gar nicht mehr
für sie ist ja dann auch die Stadt
wichtig der Autoverkehr in der Stadt für
die ältere Dame aber da sagen Sie mir
die ältere Damen soll aber dann mit dem
Fahrrad kommen zum Geschäft oder wie
meinen Sie das um zu verstehen nee also
ich habe jetzt gar nicht gesagt dass wir
unsere Städte komplett autofrei machen
wollen das ist so vielleicht äh das ist
so vielleicht die Utopie aber ich weiß
auch in Amsterdam da gibt es z.B winzige
Autos die sind so groß wie ein
Quadratmeter diesen Platz nehmen sie weg
und da fahren
ältere Frauen tatsächlich die nicht so
gut zu Fuß oder mit Fahrrad unterwegs
sind die fahren dadurch die kleinen
Gäste die sind elektrisch die Autos die
nehmen ein Quadratmeter in Fläche weg
also es geht ja nicht immer mit dem mit
dem Hammer jetzt alle Autos aus den
Städten zu schmeißen ne es geht darum
etwas Kreativität weiten zu lassen wie
können wir den Platz also die die Fläche
die er begrenzt ist in der Stadt
effizient
nutzbar haben Sie Lust auf dieses kleine
Auto z.B was gerade beschrieben wurde
sie nehmen damit ganz egal
also ich habe vor allen Dingen Lust auf
eine menschengerecht gestartet und für
mich gehören auch Auto Fahrerin
Autofahrer zu Menschen das können Sie
jetzt anders sehen aber was spricht
gegen sichere Radwege überhaupt nichts
was spricht dagegen dem Radfahren eine
neue Priorität einzuräumen auch unter
Gesichtspunkt CO2 Vermeidung gar nichts
was spricht dagegen Städtebau so zu
betreiben dass man den Autofahrern das
Autofahren unmöglich macht alles wir
wurden nicht alle um flachen Land wir
wurden ja alle in Utrecht können Sie die
höchste Erhebung der Niederlande
ja genau
bitte nicht so als könnte jeder der
mobil sein muss mit dem Fahrrad fahren
kann nicht jeder wir haben ja natürlich
kommt gleich Lastenräder wir haben die
Handwerker wir haben die Zulieferungen
darum geht es gar nicht doch der
Einzelhandel betrieben das heißt Sie
müssen allen Verkehrsträgern sicheren
Verkehrsraum geben und ich sage 1 wenn
sie es so machen wie in Berlin an der
Friedrichstraße oder bei mir zu Hause in
der berühmten Laurentiusstraße wo der
Verkehrsversuch nach Wien hat viel Geld
gekostet pumpt wieder abgebrochen worden
weil überhaupt keine Akzeptanz hat
wiegen sie die Bevölkerung auf wenn Sie
eine Wende haben wollen geht das nur mit
der Bevölkerung nicht gegen die
Bevölkerung beteiligt
müssen aufhören so ideologisch
aufgeladen zu argumentieren also der
gute auf beiden Seiten übrigens die
anderen Fahrradfahrer fehlte Fahrrad
Fetisch der gute Fahrradfahrer habe ich
jetzt gerade wieder rausgehört dann
gibt's keine schreien Holland wissen gar
nicht wie oft ich Mittelfinger schon
gezeigt bekommen habe vom Fahrradfahrer
wie viele Fußgänger sich Beschwerden
über Fahrradfahrer raus ist auch das ist
eine Frage des Charakters des Menschens
wie er sich hinter einem Fahrzeug Opfer
hat oder PKW verhält wir müssen die
Möglichkeiten schaffen dass eben die
ältere Dame Menschen die nicht Fahrrad
fahren können eben nicht abgekoppelt
werden gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
Anreize schaffen Anrei abschaffen
könnten das war ja so in die Richtung
haben sie dann ja auch argumentiert das
muss aber mit den Menschen gehen und
nicht gegen die Menschen und an dieser
Stelle ist da ein bisschen die Rhetorik
später auch eine ganz wichtige Rolle
Weilchen Taste jetzt mal ehrlich das
sind Anreiz geschaffen wird dass man
auch für Kurzstrecken das Auto in die
Stadt nimmt obwohl man das vielleicht
auch zu finden könnte Alternative ist ja
dann 50 Centurion Euro einschmeißen zu
müssen die Alternative ist sich ein
Parkplatz zu suchen und ganz normal für
den zu bezahlen
ja ja
nicht lange Spaziergänge oder Einkäufer
machen sondern nur mal schnell zum
Bäcker wollen das ist bürgerfreundlich
damit haben Sie ein Problem
soziale Frage wenn ich ähm also bauen
die Fahrrad in Hamburg bauen wir die
Fahrradwege Velo Routen auf vorbildlich
wie sich das gehört und gleichzeitig
spielen wir die einzelnen
Verkehrsteilnehmer nicht gegeneinander
gedacht alles so wie es jetzt ist es
perfekt und da kommt ein Typ und der
möchte gerne irgendwas verändern also
derzeitige Verkehrssystem ist ungerecht
es nimmt nicht alle Menschen nicht der
Kampf gegen das Auto und gegen den
Verkehr ja der ist nicht nur hier am
Tisch da und wir schauen noch mal rein
ja man sieht jetzt hier schon mal ja ich
würde sagen
ganz klar die A100 und dann sehen wir
jetzt hier die Klima Kleber
die sich da jetzt auch hinkleben also
man kennt das ist schon aus der
Fußgängerzone jetzt ist es auch auf der
Autobahn soweit was ja auch ein großes
Verkehrsrisiko hat ich glaube da würde
jetzt sogar
ja sie wird mir doch zustimmen oder ja
weil das ist doch ein riesiges riesige
ich meine sie noch die A100 das ist eine
Autobahn und dann hinkleben ist doch ein
riesiges Risiko das ist in der Tat ein
riesig für Kinder
soweit gehen im Kampf gegen das Auto
also das was die letzte Generation macht
ist ein symbolischer Kampf für mehr
Klimaschutz das es geht nicht darum sich
vor diese Menschen zu stellen und zu
sagen ihr sollt jetzt hier nicht weiter
Auto fahren weil ihr schadet im Klima es
ist ein symbolischer Aktivismus um die
größtmögliche Aufmerksamkeit
maximale Größe die letzte Generation ich
finde das Wort klimakleber etwas
abwertend aber da steckt das Wort Klima
drin und das ist genau das was die
letzte Generation will dass man übers
Klima spricht nicht nur über die Aktion
sondern auch über das Anliegen was sie
haben ich denke wir sind uns alle hier
doch einig dass das Anliegen was die
letzte Generation vorträgt dass das
richtig ist ich dachte keine einzige
Straftat übers Klima
Geschichte
durchaus auch gesetzlich spricht dir die
Frage ist erreicht man dafür mehr
Akzeptanz oder weniger jeder klimakleber
erreicht genau das Gegenteil das ist das
Gegenteil von rational
naja dachten
Generation wäre wenn eine Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft hinter ihnen hätten sie
ihre progressive Kraft und hätten sie
das aufgebraucht das müssen unbequem ist
es ist mega egoistisch wenn man sein
politischen Willen in einer Demokratie
nicht mit demokratischen Wahlen umsetzt
und dann versucht mit Gewalt
ich bin ja ein Freund von Vorbildern
gerade wenn es so um so revolutionäre
Ideen geht wie sie ja mitgebracht haben
aus Utrecht dass man eine Stadt nur noch
mit dem Fahrrad was im Prinzip ja toll
ist ich finde immer gut wenn es Menschen
gibt die so etwas fordern wenn sie das
auch vormachen und wir hatten ja den
Fall hier auch in Berlin einer
verkehrsin geboren Bettina jaraschier im
Wahlkampf im vorletzten Wahlkampf ja
noch gesagt hat wenn sie dann Senatorin
sein sollte dann würde sie alles mit dem
Fahrrad machen in Berlin war ja dann
auch umweltsenatoren es hat genau zwei
Monate gedauert und dann ist Frau
jarasch auf ihren Dienstwagen
umgestiegen Begründung war ja sie müsste
jetzt im Auto fahren sie hätte immer von
termintreff zu Termin so viele Akten
mitzuschleppen und hat sich dann auch
sogar nicht entblößt zu einer Einladung
eines Fahrradweges dann mit dem
Dienstwagen vorzufahren die letzten 100
Meter mit dem Fahrrad aber das sind doch
ablenkungs-
das zeigt doch einfach nur den
Realitätscheck das heißt eine eine
Politikerin die mit diesem Heeren Ziel
antriebt alles per Fahrrad machen zu
wollen machen zu müssen und das auch am
liebsten für jeden anderen möchte selbst
nach zwei Monaten am neuen Job nicht in
der Lage mehr dieses eigene Ziel von ihr
durchzusetzen ja und dann ich weiß nicht
was das für ein Argument ist also
wirklich wirklich
politischen Gesellschaft wir müssen
keine heilige sein um etwas
Problem wenn sie anderen Leuten
vorschreiben wollen niemanden etwas
vorstellen
sie wollen eine Fahrradstadt und es gibt
Menschen in diesem Land die auch
Politiker sind die propagieren das auch
und dann sollten doch genau diese
Politiker Vorbild sein und ihre Idee
auch umsetzen und dann trifft diese Idee
auf die Wirklichkeit und die
Wirklichkeit ist offenbar so schwer
umzusetzen da selbst eine Politikerin
die sich Ihren Terminplan mehr oder
weniger selbst leben kann erleben kann
nicht in der Lage ist dann komplett aus
fahren ich glaube sie haben mich
absichtliche oder unabsichtlich etwas
falsch verstanden ich sage nicht liebe
Leute geht jetzt alle aufs Fahrrad ich
habe doch Bilder von Österreich
mitgebracht ja alles offen es geht um
eine um eine positive Vision mein Appell
geht direkt an die Politik und sagt baut
endlich sichere Fahrradwege damit die
Menschen die Fahrrad fahren wollen und
es gibt Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland die wissen das noch gar
nicht weil sie noch nie auf einer so
guten Infrastruktur unterwegs sein wie
zum Beispiel erst recht mein Appell geht
doch an die Politik ich sage doch nicht
Leute geht das raus aufs Fahrrad ich
fahre jedenfalls beschwert sie haben
sich gerade darüber beschwert das
Autofahrer in die Stadt fahren dass das
quasi das ist doch noch möglich der
Konflikt genau und das Problem warum ist
keine sicheren Radwege zum Beispiel in
Berlin gibt ist weil das Auto enorm viel
Platz wegnimmt und was der Boss was sagt
ist ja schön er hat nichts gegen sichere
Radwege das glaube ich Ihnen ja aber in
der Realität haben wir halt nicht diesen
unendlichen Platz in der Realität muss
der sicheren Radweg zur Kosten von
Parkplätzen oder in der Regel in der
Realität sind Politiker die das sogar
wollen im Rad sich sofort zu bewegen gar
nicht selbst in der Lage und wie soll
der Handwerksmeister das machen wie soll
die ältere Dame der ältere Herr das
machen wenn schon wenn schon Politiker
Ende 40 nicht in der Lage sind die
eigenen Zielen und ein Politiker und die
anderen nicht ein Politiker kommt sehr
viel rum und ich habe in keinster Weise
gesagt dass ein Handwerker jetzt eine
Fahrrad unterwegs sein soll das ist auch
wieder so eine in den aber
nee der baust schaffen wir dann keine
Partnerschaft
Beschäftigten hatten dann nicht das
Recht mit dem Auto zu fahren die Frau
jarasch beispielsweise es geht doch im
ersten Schritt darum Alternativen zu
schaffen so dass alle Menschen ein
gleichwertiges Mobilitätsangebot haben
wir sehen in Berlin wir haben fünf
spurige Straßen und der Radweg ist 80 cm
und bestimmt aus Backstein also habe ich
sehr sehr viel geändert ich glaube da
sollten Sie in Berlin genau in keinster
Weise gleichwertige Verhältnisse für
alles
Privilegien bei dem Thema schaffen wir
heute keine green mehr hier an diesem
Tisch Einigung ist ja auch gar nicht
immer unsere Stärke deswegen kurz
Unterbrechung da sind wir wieder zurück
bis gleich wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie